well then last night 60 minutes
interview Lesley Stahl asked President
Trump about his controversial
immigration policy to separate families
which he halted in June when you don't
do separate when you allow the parents
to stay together okay when you allow
that then what happens is people are
going to pour into our country you're
gonna go back to that well we're looking
at a lot of things really what we want
to do is change the immigration laws
because they were they're a
laughingstock all over the world are you
willing though I think that you're
saying you're it's under consideration
no I want all the laws changed Leslie
for coming into our country illegally
arrests of migrant families at the
border which have been climbing all year
surged after the administration ended
family separation there were nearly
13,000 arrests in August
that's almost tripled the amount in the
same month last year Immigration and
Customs Enforcement says its border
region detention facilities are so
overwhelmed most migrants are being
processed and released
Mireya Villarreal is at Nogales Arizona
Marais a good morning well good morning
Border Patrol agents do tell us they are
seeing larger groups of these family
units crossing here along the Arizona
border some of these groups are as large
as 300 people they are mostly coming
from El Salvador Guatemala and Honduras
but they are no longer running from
these agents in fact some of these
groups are actually seeking out the
agents turning themselves in and then
asking for asylum as you said earlier so
these detention centers here at Arizona
are so overwhelmed the government is now
relying on churches to help house
migrants one pastor told us late last
week 800 people were brought to them in
one day in Tucson the ice field office
in Tucson has seen a 51 percent increase
in family apprehensions compared to this
time last year a migrant mother that we
spoke with says she decided to cross the
border with her child after the
administration ended the family
separation policy and many of these
families have been brought into the US
by smugglers Border Patrol says these
smugglers are taking advantage of the
change in policy to prey on vulnerable
would-be migrants
many of them about what to say or what
to do to gain asylum here in the US now
all of these families still have to
appear in federal court for immigration
hearings and proceedings but with over
two hundred and seventy thousand people
arrested since the beginning of the year
it will be a while before those cases
are closed Nora
Minaya thank you good reporting
interesting to hear too that those that
are trying to migrate into the United
States are listening to what the current
policy is about what will happen to them
and their families which is a White
House's point they want you they want
you to listen and they want it to be a
deterrent and now they're thinking no
not so much